ANDREW: All right.
Good afternoon, everybody.
And welcome to KitchenSync,
the Download on Food, Google's
teaching kitchen.
My name is Andrew.
And I'm the cafe manager
here at the KitchenSync Cafe.
And it is my honor today to
present a very special guest.
She is the chef and owner of
several fantastic restaurants,
including the Michelin-star
rated The Breslin in New York
City, the Michelin-star
rated The Spotted Pig
in New York City, as well,
as well as in San Francisco,
of Tosca.
She's a two-time author.
Her brand new book
is on shelves right
now, "A Girl and Her Greens."
She's the James Beard
Award winner for 2014
for Best Chef in New York City.
And you may have seen
her on such television
shows as PBS's "A Mind of a
Chef" and "Iron Chef America."
Please, everybody join me
in welcoming Chef April
Bloomfield.
[APPLAUSE]
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: Hi, guys.
Welcome, welcome.
I appreciate you
taking your lunch break
to come watch me cook.
And I just wanted to
quickly say thank you
to the team, Google
team over here,
doing your-- we
have tasters today.
So thank you guys for helping
organize everything today.
So a big hand for them.
OK.
So as you know, I've come
out with a brand new book.
It's called "A Girl
and Her Greens."
I basically wanted to show
a different side of myself
from my last book.
I want to show you my
love of vegetables.
I love vegetables.
I grew up eating them
when I was a little girl.
I was eating peas, carrots,
things like parsnips,
lots of potatoes, broccoli.
I loved everything
about broccoli.
All those kind of
Brassicas I really enjoy.
And I wanted to show this
off in my book, "A Girl
and Her Greens."
So I'm going to make you
two recipes from the book.
I've got one that I'm
about to show you.
It's basically a smashed pea.
It's the best thing
you're ever going
to eat in your whole life.
But then you're going
to eat the carrots.
And they're pretty good, too.
So basically, just
a thing about peas
when you go buy
them at the market,
try and find peas that are not
overstuffed in their shell.
So I'm going to pass
you a couple around.
You can feel these
ones, the bigger ones
are bursting their
edges a little bit.
So I'm just going
to open them up.
And you can see how
they get square.
Once they start to get square,
they get really starchy.
So you're looking for peas that
don't have as much-- I don't
know if you guys can see that.
They don't have as
much pea to them.
See how these ones are
all shoved in there.
They get a bit starchy.
These are going to
be nice and sweet.
So I'm going to pass them
around so you can just
have a long look.
Do you want to--
ANDREW: Sure.
APRIL BLOOMFIELD:
So try and find
peas that are just a good size.
And this is basically
an uncooked mushy pea.
Everybody know what
a mushy pea is?
Anybody been to England?
Yeah.
Have you had fish and
chips with mushy peas?
They're basically
like long-cooked peas
that are stewed for--
I don't know, well,
it depends who's cooking them.
Could be really bad.
But they're really
stewed from anywhere
for like an hour to 25 minutes.
So in here, I've got some peas.
It's not many.
It's probably like a pound.
A little bit of mint
and some garlic.
We're basically making a pesto.
OK.
And a pesto just means paste.
So I'm going to add some salt.
This will help flavor the peas.
They'll bring out
some sweetness.
I've got some
garlic, mint, salt.
And I'm just going to
give it a little whiz.
And you can do it on Pulse.
And you can either do this
really, really smooth.
Or you can do it
a little mixture
of both smooth and chunky.
It just depends on
personal preference.
I'm going to make
mine nice and smooth.
Just give it a little
whiz like this.
Can you smell that mint?
I can smell that mint already.
Smells really springy.
This is the best thing after
being kind of holed up-- well,
maybe not in
California-- holed up
in the winter in New York City,
and there's not a green thing
around.
Having these poke up
through the ground
and seeing them at the
market, I don't know.
I get really excited
about that kind of stuff.
So the first thing in spring,
this is the best thing to make.
In here, I just
put some Pecorino.
It's a little aged Pecorino.
So it has a little
complexity to it.
And so it's a little bit funky.
So it really just adds
something to the pea.
It really just elevates
the whole mush.
It looks good.
I think I'm going to go
with some olive oil, too.
Can you guys see this?
There we are.
Yeah.
OK, good.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Very nice.
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: OK.
So then actually, you
could put the olive oil in,
Or you could just use the bowl.
But I'm just going to use the
bowl now that I got it off.
I might not be able
to get it back on,
so-- They're a bit
temperamental, things things.
You could do this in a
pestle and mortar, actually.
It's quite fun.
Anybody got a pestle
and mortar at home?
Yeah?
Just do them in small batches
so your peas don't just
fly all over the place and
you're trying to catch them.
A little bit of olive oil.
That's a lot of olive oil.
It's still healthier
than butter.
I mean, come on.
So just give that
a really good mix.
And it'll just go a
little wee bit creamy.
And then now you've
got all that fat.
You've got a little bit
of the cheese in there.
It's not too much.
It's not overpowering
the peas at all.
You've got some of the
olive oil, again, which
is slightly more fatty.
You've got that sweet peas.
So everything's going to
be quite heavy right now.
So the way we balance
that out is just
a little bit of olive oil.
So we're just going
to add a little bit.
And we're just
going to taste it.
AUDIENCE: Are you
separately seasoning?
Or are you just using the
salt and the Pecorino?
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: No, I
added a little bit of salt
in with my bowl.
Somebody wasn't
paying attention.
[LAUGHTER]
I was only-- [LAUGHING]
I'm just kidding.
Too many nights at Tosca,
that's what it is, yeah.
AUDIENCE: By the bar upstairs?
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: Right.
Yeah, that's right.
So I'm going to give a taste.
It's always good to taste.
So let's just-- it's good.
It's got some mint in there.
So it's not too much.
It's not overtaking the pea.
It's got a little lemon.
And so it's really
bright at the beginning.
But then you get this nice
salty, earthy, clean pea
flavor.
And you can see how
creamy it's gone.
And it's spreadable.
It's a nice paste.
So my next job is to do some
bruschetta, which is basically
just a tasted bread,
usually rubbed
with a little bit of
garlic and then finished
with some salt and
some olive oil.
This is a nice San
Francisco sourdough.
You guys make the best
bread, San Francisco.
So you're very lucky.
So just give it a good old cut.
Get a nice little piece
for yourself like this.
And then you can just
pop it on the grill.
And actually, you can
take this quite far.
I kind of like that
bitterness that you
get from a little bit
of the charred bread.
I think it complements
the sweetness from the pea
really well.
For breakfast, if I'm doing
a bit of toast and jam,
I like to get a bit
more burnt edges on it.
Because it compliments
that sweetness, too.
But lots of butter, of course.
You've got to have your butter.
So just keep that on there until
it gets all nice and toasty.
And you want to take
it quite crunchy.
If you don't, it's just going
to kind of "bloop," drip off.
And then it's going
to be in your lap.
And everybody's going to
think you're a lazy eater
and you have no manners.
So yeah, just kind
of toast that.
Let it sit.
Sometimes it's good to let
things just chill for a second.
Not 20 minutes, but
just-- and then we'll
have another little taste.
So you taste at the beginning,
middle, and the end.
Did you guys all see those peas?
Did anybody get to taste?
Did you taste one?
You should taste them, too.
Sometimes they come with
their shells a little bit
more rough-looking.
Some are nice and green.
It doesn't mean that the peas
are any worse inside if they're
a little bit brown, like this.
And taste.
When you go to the market-- San
Francisco's amazing for this--
but always make sure
you taste stuff.
And ask.
Sometimes you get told off
if you just help yourself.
I've been told off many times.
Terrible.
But always taste.
Always ask to taste.
San Francisco's really amazing.
Because they actually
cut stuff for you.
They kind of put it out.
You get your little
toothpick and taste.
So that's kind of fun.
And give things a little smell.
Touch things.
Have a little look.
See where they're at.
Because that's the
only way you're
going to get more experienced
on picking your vegetables.
It's just like
buying a bit of fish.
When you go to a fish market,
you want clear eyes, red gills.
You want it to
look nice and firm.
A little bit of slime around
the fish is important.
It usually means that
it's freshly caught,
it hasn't been out of
the water very long.
And if it's
flat-looking, tired--
it's basically like picking a
handsome man, really, you know.
It's got to look
pretty sexy, right?
Or a woman.
Anyway, so this toast
is pretty much done.
You see how I got these nice
dark, charred bits on there?
That's really going to
just elevate this dish.
Oh, I need a plate to plate.
Thank you.
Give it a nice rub of garlic.
Even though there's a little
bit of garlic in here,
it's nice to just
layer those flavors.
Thank you.
Oh, and a bit of
arugula, please, too.
Thank you.
So it's nice to
layer those flavors.
So this is quite
bulky and thick.
So I'm just going to give it
a little bit more salt. Again,
getting all those flavors
layered in is really important.
And then I'm going to do
a really good, big lashing
of olive oil on the bread.
Because again, it's quite bulky.
You don't want this
dry piece of bread.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: There's that.
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: Great.
Thanks.
And then you just get a good,
healthy scoop of the pea.
Pop it on the plate like this.
And then just start
at the round end.
I'm going to go more.
Because I like peas.
And just give it a good
old smash down on there.
If some falls on the
plate, it's kind of cool.
It looks like a little bit
of a garnish, doesn't it?
That's our little
secret, just so you know.
OK.
So I'm going to
just garnish this.
You can go extra mint.
You know what would be
really great on here
is some pea shoots,
little pea flowers.
I'm using the arugula.
It should be nice and spicy.
If you're using
pea shoots, they're
normally quite nice and sweet.
And just lightly
drizzle some olive oil.
I did salt. Yes, did
a little bit of salt
and a little bit of
olive oil on top.
And when you dress your
salads, if they're delicate,
don't go in there like, "pff,"
like a bull in a China shop.
You want to just gently dress.
So the way I do it is I
either use these little two
fingers as a little claw.
And I just gently
toss like this.
Or I use, actually, the bowl.
I just gather my
fingers up like this.
And I gently push the
salad against the bowl.
And then I let it drop.
And so I kind of
do this movement.
And it's usually
good for doing salads
so you don't get bruised leaves.
And just arrange
it nice and fancy.
Because then everybody thinks
you're sophisticated and smart.
And then just a little
bit of olive oil.
That's really easy, right?
All you have to do
is pod the peas.
And I made that in like,
I think, five minutes.
But it was probably 10 minutes.
But there you go.
So that's that first dish.
Do you guys like that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
that looks great.
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: Good.
[APPLAUSE]
How many people would
make that at home?
It's so easy, right?
So if you don't want to
just have it on bread,
you know what's great is
if you boil a bit of pasta,
you put some cream in,
maybe a little garlic,
and then just toss
this through, or a bit
of Parmesan or Pecorino.
You can use the Pecorino
If you don't have Parmesan,
by the way.
I forgot to say that.
And then just toss some
pasta all the way through.
If you don't have mint,
you can use basil.
All those things that you can
substitute that go really well,
feel free to use them.
OK.
Next dish is another
favorite of mine.
It's basically roasted
carrots with burrata.
Roasting is sometimes quite
scary for people, right?
Who likes roasting carrots
and veggies and-- oh,
you're all pretty good, then.
Nice.
It was just me, then.
Oh well.
The reason why I think
people are very fearful
of cooking veggies,
or not successful,
is that sometimes they
cut them too small.
So by the end of it,
they're all shriveled up.
And there's no
substance to them.
And then other times
they roast them,
and they don't have any color.
Because they're too small.
Because then they're
going to overcook.
And they're going to burn.
So keeping your vegetables
a little bit more chunky
allows you to be able to
get some more sweetness
and caramelization from
the carrot, or the veg,
without overcooking.
So I like to just them
very gently in a pan.
Just layer them up like this.
Top and tail so you
can fit a few more in.
You can throw some on
the top and stir them
around again, too, if you want.
And then just let them go
on a medium to high heat,
depending on what kind
of veggies they are.
And then get a nice
little color on them.
While they're
browning like this,
I'm going to start my pesto.
I'm just smash-mad today.
I'm going pesto crazy.
So I'm going to make
another little pesto.
And I'm going to
use the carrot tops.
How many of you knew that
you could eat carrot tops?
I only learned that like
a couple of years ago.
So you're very, very
smart for knowing that.
OK.
So carrot tops, they're
exactly what they are.
They're tops of the carrots.
So these are nice.
They're all structured.
There's no blemishes
on them at all.
And you could just basically
take off the tops like this.
You don't want to
go too far down.
Sometimes they get a little
tougher towards the end.
And then just pick them off
like this, leaving the stalk on.
This one, even this,
this is tender here.
So leaving this stalk
on right there is good.
And just the same kind of
process, just pop them all in.
Did I drop a carrot?
Oops.
My poor little carrots
have dropped on the floor.
OK.
Look how nice that one looks.
Look at that.
Looks like a Christmas tree.
I'm going to save that
for my garnish, I think.
Maybe this one, too.
Just pick them all off.
Pop them in.
I have some more here.
Well, I did earlier.
So just do a nice little
handful like this.
These are nice.
They taste like carrots.
They're a little earthy, again.
So these earthy carrot tops
go nice with the walnuts.
So we're just going to
throw some walnuts in there.
You can use almonds.
You could use pine nuts.
I don't really like
to taste-- uh, toast.
I love to taste.
I don't like to toast.
The reason why I don't
toast is because I think
it makes for a cleaner pesto.
Sometimes when you
toast the nuts,
they get a little bit dirty.
And they can be a
bit too overpowering.
So not toasting the
nuts is a nice trick
to keeping your food fresh.
A little bit of salt. I
want plenty of garlic.
I like quite a lot of
garlic in my pesto.
Basil.
If you didn't have basil,
you could use tarragon.
Or chervil is really cool.
Chervil's like an underrated
herb, so some of that
would be great.
OK.
So just give it a good old whiz.
Again, you can have it chunky
or as smooth as you want.
Smells good.
And then I'm going to
go with some olive oil.
And you could do it runny.
Again, this in some
pasta would be great.
I'm going to get it
a little smoother.
I can't get it off.
Oh well.
I need a bowl.
Do you guys ever have this
trouble when you do your work?
Where you're like--
I don't know,
like something's not coming.
I don't know.
I don't know what the
equivalent of that would be.
But I would be very
fascinated to know.
AUDIENCE: Your laptop.
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: Oh, great.
Good job.
The laptop what?
AUDIENCE: If your
laptop crashes.
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: Oh, yeah.
That would be
awful, wouldn't it?
Oh my goodness.
That would be-- that's
just worst than this.
[LAUGHS] Oh, no.
What a nightmare.
Is there somebody you can call
when you're-- oh, my gosh.
What a nightmare.
Oh, dear.
So you can see this is really,
really nice and creamy.
And it's really just going to
brighten up your dish nicely.
So again, I'm going to
give it a little taste.
I might just let it
down-- mm, it's good--
just so I can drizzle it.
And it's really not going to
affect the flavor that much.
It's just merely to-- are you
guys laughing at the olive oil?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's
just a lot of olive oil.
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: Well, you
know, olive oil tastes good.
I know.
I go through bottles and
bottles of olive oil.
But that's why if
you want to do this,
you've got to buy some of
those things if you can,
like just an olive oil
that you really like.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
a favorite brand?
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: Yeah,
I actually usually
buy a Chilean olive
oil that's organic.
Actually, I have a really
good relationship with them.
It's called Olive.
Actually, they just changed
their name from Olave to Olive.
And it's really good.
And it's actually
not that expensive.
You can buy it from Whole Foods
if you guys ever shop there.
It's definitely a
delicious one to buy.
And we buy Tuscan olive
oils, which are great.
Because they're nice
and spicy and delicious.
So I'll just give
them a little season.
Just check them.
See if they're
getting any color.
You might not want to use
your fingers like this.
You might want to use
a spoon or something.
OK.
So I'm just going
to let this chill.
Looks pretty good, right?
Yummy.
OK.
So I've got some
carrots that I did.
So just so you can
see, because it's
going to take a long
time for them to brown.
But you can see how delicious.
They got really concentrated.
You guys see that?
They've got a nice
little bit of color.
And they're not too greasy.
[LAUGHTER]
She's all like-- she's
too busy tasting.
And I've got some yellow ones.
You can see the color on
these, which are really nice.
So actually, I wanted
pass them around
so you can actually see
how nicely cooked they are.
So if you want to just
have a little poke.
You can have a nibble,
too, if you like.
AUDIENCE: Is there
thyme in this?
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: Yeah,
a little bit of thyme.
So once they brown
a little bit, I'm
going to just throw them in the
oven with a little bit of thyme
and a little bit of garlic.
And that'll just very gently and
delicately flavor your carrots.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: No,
I didn't peel the skin.
And that's the
best thing, right?
When you get
carrots that are not
too large or beets
that are not too big,
you don't have to peel them.
You can just throw them in the
oven, cook them with their skin
on.
Saving yourself some work
when you've been working late
is really amazing.
And it's just edible, right?
Why not?
Saves you some time.
It's less waste.
It's better for the environment.
It's going all in your tummy.
And you're satisfied and happy.
OK.
So I'm going to
construct this salad.
But I need another plate.
Sorry.
ANDREW: So what's the
equivalent in the vegetable
world of the nose to tail, snout
to tail, however you call it.
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: That would
be a funny-looking pig,
wouldn't it?
ANDREW: Wouldn't it?
Yeah.
I can't even think
about it, actually.
Weird.
But yeah, this would be it.
This, cooking nose to tail, this
would be top to bottom or top
to tail.
You could do it with beets.
At The Spotted Pig,
and even at Tosca,
we have an amazing
dish-- you probably
know that-- with the beets
with the tarragon pesto.
And we use the beet greens.
And we just lightly char them on
a grill so you get everything.
We use the stalks, the leaves.
We even leave the nice little
tail on the end of the beets.
So you get this crunchy texture.
Really amazing.
So yeah, this is it.
Using broccoli stalks-- do
you guys eat broccoli stalks?
Yeah, just using those up,
not throwing them away,
just maybe peeling the
outer part of the broccoli,
because sometimes
that's the toughest.
So it's basically knowing
when to use something
and when not to.
If something's
tough, peel it back.
Because if it's tough, then
you're not going to enjoy it.
But if it's tender and sweet and
beautiful, feel free to use it.
OK.
So when these come out
of the oven, again,
you've just concentrated
all that sweetness.
You can see the theme.
The carrots are nice.
They should be a little bit
salty and a little bit sweet,
a little bit herbaceous
from the earthy rosemary
and a little bit of the
garlic from the roasted garlic
that you put in.
I really just tap each carrot
with just a touch of lemon.
Because again, the sweetness
you've concentrated.
You've got some nice color.
You've got all that flavor
rocking and working.
Really take your
time to do this.
Because you don't
want to miss one.
Because then somebody might
get the one that's not dressed.
And then they're not having
the same experience as you.
So being nice and balanced is
really important, and thinking
about the other person, too.
Again, just fresh olive oil.
She's still on her phone.
She's going to leave.
She's going to be
like, what happened?
[LAUGHS]
So just give it a
little light toss
in the remaining olive oil.
And just arrange it.
Look how cute.
Do you see these
little crispy bits?
It's no point
chopping those off.
I don't like it when
you go to a place
and it doesn't look like what
it's supposed to look like.
I love keeping
things very organic.
And if it's a carrot, make
it look like a carrot instead
of making these little squares.
I love rustic, but
delicious food.
OK So I've got that down.
And I've got some burrata
which is from Italy.
It's basically a mozzarella.
So they make a mozzarella sack.
And they shove it full
of sometimes cream
or creme fraiche and this thing
called stracciatella, which
is just shreds of mozzarella.
So basically, it's got
this nice little coat.
You guys can see it here.
Nice little skin of
mozzarella on the outside.
And then this lovely, oozy,
gooey, cheesy goodness inside.
So I get really excited
about that kind of stuff.
It's what makes my day.
You just pick this up.
It doesn't matter
if some oozes out.
Just arrange it nicely
on the plate like that.
And you get this contrast
between this lovely white cream
and then these beautiful
golden carrots.
Let's take a look at
these, by the way.
They're getting there.
And you can speed
this process up.
I'm a little scared of this
induction, just so you know.
ANDREW: I see you don't like
to use a lot of utensils
in your cooking.
[LAUGHTER]
Only when it comes
to the hot stuff
you really like to use utensils.
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: I know.
See, I'm using a spoon to
plate though, yeah, I don't.
Anyway, so it kind of looks
like an egg, doesn't it?
All right.
So I'm going to
save some of these
like I did just to put
on top as a garnish.
You could put some fresh basil
in there, too, make it nice.
Or tarragon, whatever you're
using, chervil, again.
Just a little bit
more oil and lemon.
I always do lemon first.
I think it just helps the oil
not get too greasy on the leaf.
And so it doesn't
make it as heavy.
But you could just premix.
In my "Girl and Her Pig,"
there's a recipe for lemon oil.
And its 1 to 2, so 1 lemon
to 2 oil, which is nice.
Just give it a little taste,
a little bit of a season.
You could premix that and
then just dress it with that.
Some of this lovely pesto.
Just pop some of that on top.
Don't be shy.
We'll do another
couple of carrots.
A little bit of this on top.
These are nice.
Because they've got
lots of structure.
So you can just
daintily put them on.
They don't all have to
be up the right way.
There could be one
that's upside down.
Gives it a nice little curve.
You see that there?
Nice little curve here.
Put one here, maybe upside down.
And then just finish
it with more olive oil.
And that's basically the
burrata with the carrots.
So now I'm going to
show you these carrots.
Hopefully I haven't burned them.
So this is good.
We can just throw
them in the oven now.
Just give them a little shake.
See the color
you've got on there?
So now you can just do
these in a medium oven.
And then you don't have to
worry about getting the color.
Because you've already done it.
So all you've got to do is just
pay attention to how they're
cooked.
And whether they're crunchy
or soft is dependent on you
and what you like, really.
A bit more.
OK.
And then just throw
them in the oven.
And these will take
about 10 minutes to cook.
And again, you can get the
color a little bit more faster
if you'd like.
And use a heavy-bottom pan.
Use a pan that's thick on the
bottom, not like a thin pan.
Because this'll
help all the sugars.
Whatever you're cooking, whether
it's searing meat or cooking
vegetables, it'll bring the
sugars out at a slower rate
than if you use a thin pan.
And it's more even.
So a good pan's really
important to get great food.
That's it.
That's my little
two dishes here,
the smashed peas
with the arugula
and the burrata with
the carrot top pesto.
Thanks for coming, guys.
I hope you're going to get
to eat your little nibbles.
And we're going to do a Q&A.
ANDREW: All right.
Anybody have any questions?
AUDIENCE: What
restaurants will you
visit in San Francisco
besides Tosca?
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: Oh,
that's a good question.
I'm only here on
a fleeting visit.
Because I have to go on to LA.
But yeah, I'll probably
just spend my time
at Tosca, which
is the best thing.
I love Tosca.
And I need to be
in my restaurant.
So yeah.
ANDREW: Right over here.
AUDIENCE: When you
were growing up,
did you always like vegetables?
Sorry, two parts.
And then also, what were
your biggest influences
with vegetables growing up?
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: OK.
So yeah, I loved
veggies growing up.
My Nan, actually, was the
best cook in the family.
And we always used to go
round to have a big roast
dinner, a big roast lunch.
And she was amazing.
She would get all
her mise en place
in little pots on the stove.
She'd have her peeled
potatoes covered in water.
She'd have her parsnips in a
pan ready to go in the oven.
And that was very inspiring.
She was very organized.
But yeah, I loved
roasted carrots.
I loved carrots.
I love potatoes.
I think I must have some
Irish in me somewhere.
I'm slightly obsessed
about potatoes.
But peas, I love peas.
Parsnips.
Parsnips were a little bit more
difficult. But I did eat them,
just because they were
a bit more floral.
But I worked in a restaurant
called The River Cafe where
I really got to
experience things
like parsnips and celeriac or
fennel, that a lot of people
don't like.
Because I think they
struggle with that kind
of floral, aromatic
flavor that they have.
And I don't know.
They really just opened my eyes.
And I fell in love with
that type of vegetable
at that restaurant.
And so I think you can kind
of see that come through
in the book.
Yeah, I reference The River
Cafe quite a lot in this book.
AUDIENCE: It's a
great restaurant.
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: It's amazing.
I'd still be there
now, I think, probably.
Yeah.
ANDREW: What's next?
You have five
amazing restaurants,
a couple of great books.
What's coming up?
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: What's next?
That's a good question.
I'm actually working
on a burger concept
right now that's all going to
be wood-grilled, just a really
great ale wood-grilled
burger with locally
sourced beef, which we'll
grind in-house ourselves.
Yeah.
Thank you guys.
Thanks for coming.
ANDREW: All right.
Thanks a lot, guys.
So there are books
for sale in the back.
And so please feel
free to buy a book.
And she'll be signing
books right up here.
APRIL BLOOMFIELD:
Yep, definitely.
ANDREW: OK.
Cool, thank you.
APRIL BLOOMFIELD: Great.
Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]